le lit il est un peu percé il ya des
trous de normes et enfin on le bouge
avec des journaux 1961
le sujet est rare pour l'époque yves un
étudiant de 20 ans expliquer ces
conditions de vie précaires à un
journaliste n'est pas chauffée n'en
allait pas chauffer les lundis fêterait
pas comment on se couvre plus avec les
couvertures de nuit près de 20 ans plus
tard le constat reste le même en 1982
fazia étudiante à paris vivaient avec
seulement 650 francs par mois
après avoir payé le loyer par exemple
après avoir payé la bouffe après avoir
payé les transports la carte orange
après tous ces frais là bas il nous
reste plus grand chose dans les années
90 la précarité étudiante est encore
présente
d'après 18 francs et là ma première
année je les ai perdus maintenant j'ai
plus rien je suis de faire une demande
l'aide exceptionnelle et au même si
j'obtiens cette aide je n'aurai pas le
montant ma bourse sur un montant
beaucoup faible dans les années 2000 la
précarité étudiante est bien plus
présente dans les médias avec toujours
les mêmes témoignages on peut pas
s'acheter de la viande tous les jours
moi je tire le repas de base c'est les
pattes puy-en-velay des choix de santé
parce qu'à aller consulter un médecin
m'ont effectivement on est couvert on à
la sécurité à la sécurité sociale
étudiante donc ça c'est très bien mais
avant ces 50 euros un spécialiste parce
qu'on a un problème de vente depuis deux
semaines saha planète une en bourse-
enfin ne pas le faire si de nombreuses
aides existent comme les apl l'aide à la
mobilité internationale ou plus
récemment le pass culture la précarité
reste très présente dans le milieu
étudiant
selon une enquête menée par l'insee en
2016 20,8 pour cent des étudiants vivait
sous le seuil de pauvreté
[Musique]